Київський суддя Богдан Львов - герой численних журналістських розслідувань
Він ухвалював сумнівні судові рішення
не вніс усіх даних до своєї декларації
і живе не за статками
Утім, Вища кваліфікаційна комісія суддів,
скорочено ВККС
яка займається переатестацією служителів закону
цих сторінок біографії Богдана Львова "не помітила"
Така ганебна ситуація, коли після переатестації
недоброчесний суддя залишається на посаді
радше правило, аніж виняток,
каже адвокат Віталій Титич
Він один із 20-ти активістів
Громадської ради Доброчесності
Створення такої ради було передбачено
українським законодавством
саме для нагляду за процесом відбору суддів
Однак за рік діяльності їй не вдалось
вплинути на результати конкурсу
та не допустити призначення недоброчесних суддів
ВККС діяла відповідно до свого бачення
так як вона організовує
Немає принципу ніякого, розумієте
Кого вона вирішила зробити суддею Верховного суду
того вона і зробила
Якщо вона когось на цій стадії відсіяла
і при цьому формально це співпало
з висновком Громадської ради Доброчесності
тоді це трактувалось як те
що ВККС врахувала цей висновок
До того ж, нарікають члени Ради
оцінювання перетворилося на конвеєр
де за день абияк атестують до шістдесяти суддів
виділяючи на співбесіду деяких від трьох до шести хвилин.
Юристку Галину Чижик це особливо обурює
адже лише для збору інформації про одного суддю
вона витрачає до 16 годин
Обурює й те, що кваліфікаційна комісія
не дає доступу
до суддівських досьє або ж частину засекречує
Ці та інші факти спонукали
Громадську раду Доброчесності
вийти з процесу оцінювання суддів
Якщо ми в цьому процесі залишимося
то потім, коли він закінчиться із нульовим
чи навіть від'ємним результатом для суспільства
коли всі судді, які уникнули люстрації
і фактично
для звільнення яких
і стартувала ця судова реформа
якщо вони залишаться на посадах,
то потім це буде
комунікуватись і представлятися суспільству
та нашим міжнародним партнерам як успішна реформа, в якій взяла участь громадськість
В офіційній заяві члени
Громадської ради Доброчесності
висунули свої вимоги до ВККС
Вимагають серед іншого реалістичних
графіків тестування суддів
а також прозорої процедури оцінювання суддів
та усунення тих членів комісії
які себе сумнівно зарекомендували
Однак ВККС поки що на лист
жодним чином не відреагувала
і наче нічого не сталося
далі проводить оцінювання суддів
без представників громадськості
Закон не передбачає, що співбесіда
не може відбутись без представника ГРД
або без висновку ГРД
Але це є важливий елемент
повертаючись до мети судової реформи
то навіть у пояснювальній записці до закону
”Про судоустрій і статус суддів”
який президент вносив у парламент,
було чітко зафіксовано
що ця судова реформа відбудеться успішно
тому що безпосердню участь у процесі бере громадськість
у вигляді Громадської Ради Доброчесності
В умовах, коли українська влада ніяк не реагує
на проблему зриву суддівської реформи
члени Громадської ради Доброчесності сподіваються на реакцію західних партнерів
Адже причини для занепокоєня очевидні
кваліфікаційне оцінювання пройшли
вже понад триста суддів
За новим законом вони вже "доброчесні"
а отже мають отримувати гідну заробітну плату
Так, за даними ради,
в одіозного судді Богдана Львова
офіційний місячний дохід зріс удесятеро
із 25 тисяч гривень до 250 тисяч
Та найгірше, що після оцінювання він та інші судді
отримали, по суті, індульгенцію
за якою в майбутньому їх буде ще важче
притягти до відповідальності